ponot girard faut-il une justice
d'exception pour pour les djihadistes
d'abord il faut dire que c'est dommage
quand les ehpad tous tués sur place donc
ma première préconisation stratégique
c'est parce qu'on a des militaires c'est
essayer de les tuer sur place ceux qui
reviennent et qui sont pris par la
police ou qui se donne à la police sur
le territoire français ben je vais vous
dire ça dépend du nombre
si ils sont très nombreux on va pas
pouvoir faire des procès à lamérac
partout donc il va falloir une justice
d'exception
ça dépend en fait ça dépend du nombre de
gens vous avez à juger et toutes les
justices d'exception souvent des garçons
sont sont dus au fait du nombre de
nombre d'accusés que vous avez que vous
avez à traiter moi personnellement
moralement ça ne me gêne absolument pas
que il ya une justice d'exception contre
des gens d'une façon qui méprisent d'un
très adroit qui méprisent notre
démocratie qui méprisent toutes les
valeurs que nous professons et qui pense
d'ailleurs que ces valeurs sont de la
faiblesse donc en fait vous voyez bien
que j'ai raison de vous combattre vous
regardez bien que vous vous êtes faible
puisque vous vous embarrasser de me
faire des procès qui vont couvrir les 20
millions d'euros et puis parce que vous
continuez à lorsque je suis parti me
battre avec des djihadistes de l'état
islamique ont continué à me verser mais
moins rs à mes indemnités
ma sécurité sociale etc et bien non je
suis dans une guerre si effectivement
comme l'a dit le président rowland nous
sommes dans une guerre
eh bien je considère qu'il faut être
impitoyable